i'm here with one of my favorites rywood
jr
and we were just talking in the break
about what we're watching on tv and so
we're going to talk a little tv all
right the hollywood reporter says that
emily in paris has just been picked up
for not one but two more seasons
buy netflix
and i gotta tell you i produced a show
on netflix called santa clarita diet i
know how that studio functions and this
is a big deal for them to grant two
seasons to something so it's obviously
going gangbusters i'm so happy for them
and i gotta say i binge the second
season in one one day
what
are you currently watching roy what are
you binging what should we all be
watching i am finally at a point
with regards to just my workload where i
can actually plug back into stuff that's
on tv so i'm just i'm devouring sitcoms
right now uh grand cru on nbc i love and
abbott elementary on abc i think they're
two of the best shows out right now
they're saying grand cru is like the new
friends yeah i like grand cru because
it's just it's just black people just
hanging out and being black and existing
and paying bills and dating and it's
it's not
slavery every two lines it's like we
know the stresses of being a minority
but also it's dope to just see people
just existing in their world and just
dealing with everyday
dating and the mundane all the way to
the extreme okay and is there any stand
up because i have been watching your
special that's coming out and i'm
freaking out i love the filler talk i
love
when you're saying about the one
cast member who has to take one for the
team
tell historical movies i was just like
eating it up i love it so much so
obviously we're all going to watch your
show
and that's going to go in the little
yellow book as a suggestion which is our
personal curation of everything you
think we think you should get watch
check out by
having your life to make it better but
is there any comedy that you think we
should look out for there are two
stand-up comedians that just had uh
netflix specials okay that i thought
were really funny um well there was
naomi there's brian simpson and janelle
james janelle james plays the principal
on abbott elementary okay so like just
very very funny stand-ups but if you go
watch the stand-ups on netflix there's a
lot of great comedians yeah right now
you know when you look at
where we are as a country you know and
like
like
let's take bob saget
yes
when you look at
the
the stretch of work that he did
for decades and it's easy to forget just
how much someone delivering a laugh to
you on a weekly basis time and time
again all the way from america's
funniest home videos all the way to full
house all the way to full like to be
able to do that and impact people you
know it's it's a gift and an honor and
the people who do it well you know they
should always be celebrated i think
that's why they've always been my heroes
and bob saget was an incredible person i
hung out with him one night i'll never
forget it it was at this hotel
uh in in hollywood and i was sitting
with him and joe cocker
and uh we were throwing some drinks back
and hanging out
and uh i remember laughing because he
like talked dirty and said swear words
and i had only you know i'd been
watching him on full house and i was
like oh this is so cool
i can talk the way i talk in front of
him
and he was just so lovely and real and
funny and cool and when you see this
outpour even his last tweets were so
gracious to people
and um comedians do
an incredible service
to humanity at and they should be seen
as that yeah i just think it's important
to remember that every comedian is just
trying to heal you while healing himself
yes
exactly
exactly
well
on that note i think um you know
maybe all of us could um
tell each other a joke or if somebody
you know is going through it do
everything you can to lighten their load
make them laugh and be appreciative of
all the comedians out there who are
brave enough to do that for us
including
[Applause]
imperfect messenger coming to paramount
plus on january 19th i've seen it i love
it you're gonna love it too
[Music]